popular sites across las vegas you may
notice are covered in purple this week
it's all for national crime victims
rights week yeah bianca holman live this
morning from las vegas city hall with
more on that good morning to you bianca
hey good morning alex good morning john
so i'm here in front of city hall and
this is one of a dozen sites across the
valley
that's going to be lit up in purple and
this year there's an
emphasis and a focus on marsy's law so a
little bit more information about
marshy's law and
this national week that we're
recognizing this was an effort passed by
voters in 2018
it ensures crime victims and their
families have information about their
case
it's named for marcy nicholas who was
murdered by her ex-boyfriend in
california in the 1980's
crime victims week was established 40
years ago to recognize victims across
the country
and in 83 the office of victims of
crimes was created
our state is working to keep victims
safe and in the loop with updates during
court proceedings and notifications if a
defendant is released from prison or
jail
if we didn't have these rules in the
body of the constitution for the state
of nevada
there was always the possibility that
they didn't have to be recognized and so
with this recognition now in the
constitution it solidifies those rights
for victims
that is one of 10 states that have
passed some form of marsy's law
and coming up in the next half hour
we're going to share more about how this
impacts
victims of crimes and their families
reporting from downtown bianca holman
8 news now